[Android Developer Story]
[RogerVoice]
[DEVELOPING ON ANDROID FIRST]
I grew up with over 80% hearing lose,
but that hasn't stopped me from
doing so many things in my life.
Being an entrepreneur I'm use to having a sense
of freedom in doing what I want.
And I knew that I could do something about
accessibility in telecommunications for deaf people.
RogerVoice is an APP that allows deaf people
to make phone calls.
The notion is quite simple.
You're trying to use voice recognition
to capture the other person's voice,
so that I can read what you are saying.
It's not like I was looking for solutions.
I was just looking for something to help me.
When I realized there was
something much more to it,
I knew right away that I had to make this happen
for a lot of other people.
My goal is to make it as
accessible as possible to everybody.
I knew that Android had the way to reach each other.
Over one billion users today, which is massive.
And the fact that Android had like no constraints,
I didn't have to ask myself it this was possible
or not possible, I could just do it,
so that was a deciding factor.
I had no skills to start with.
I couldn't code. I couldn't design.
I had to find people, find skills.
It's at that point where you
realize you can do a lot of things,
but needed all of these connections
around you to make it happen.
When Olivier came to me, the first thing we did
was rethinking the navigation.
And here we are building
an APP that plays on accessibility.
I wanted to make something really clear
and easy to use, and
Material Design really helped me.
All these guidelines are really clear.
The versions of the application in Android are
iterated easily,
and development of the whole
APP took about 3 months.
When I made the APP, and it was a great moment,
I was just like "Wow, this is
so cool, I can call my mom now."
And I spent the next 24 hours
calling everybody in the world.
All my friends.
Before launching the product,
GooglePlay is offering a Beta program
for meeting deaf people
specifically to test the APP.
And so there's people in Canada trying the APP out.
There's people in Kuwait.
There's somebody in Japan.
It's not like a game where if you have a bug,
you just fix it, it's supposed to be a life-changing
experience for a person with hearing disabilities.
If it doesn't work well,
it will be really disappointing.
So with thanks to the beta testing program,
we were able to get it right
from the first public version.
What I enjoy the most developing
RogerVoice application on droid is that
I create something that
really matters to the end-users.
I feel like when you release something out there,
it's like end of story.
Then you can think about it another way.
You can be like "Okay, you've gone this far,
but now there's so much more to do."
I see that probably the
biggest evolution going forward.
Put accessibility as the major
component of development and design.
And I'm proud to be part of that trend.